5 years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe but the people
of this planet brought everyone back with a snap
of a finger the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have seven days
we're eternals we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or any war
all the other terrible things throughout history
we were instructed not to interfere in any human
conflicts unless deviants are involved by who
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for centuries
hi hello this is what the end of the world
looks like at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved
the planet you're sarcasm
we have loved these people since the
day we arrived when you love something
you protect it
you can't protect
any of them
I bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection ikea
Welcome back everyone big
surprise marvel dropped a new eternals trailer
at midnight last night it's been a while since
anyone's done that so we'll break it down this
is going to be my quick reaction video i will
make some bigger longer videos soon about some
of the bigger easter eggs here and what's going on
with the celestials the deviants and the eternals
characters if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos the big thing
here is they want to give you the actual story
and i think i talked a little bit about this in
my last trailer video but they actually show
you the celestials that's probably one of the
biggest things here is revealing what they're
going to look like in the film and they make a
really big deal about explaining why they didn't
help out with avengers end game probably the
biggest question that people had since the
movie was announced if they're so powerful
why didn't they help and they used kit
harington's black knight character to do that
they justify by saying they weren't supposed to
interfere in the affairs of man the funny thing
that they don't address during this though is
that thanos is an eternal from titan and he does
carry the deviant gene so technically a deviant or
someone with a deviant gene was attacking humanity
in the rest of the universe there'll be so many
comments about that when the movie comes out and
i'm sure they'll have some moment in the movie
that will address that even more because they
do talk about the snaps in the blip but they
give you the ticking clock here seven days
till the end of the earth in the emergence what
they're talking about is the emergence of the
next celestial there's a celestial growing inside
planet earth and celestials are massive massive
beings so if you've ever watched a chicken hatch
out of an egg it's going to be kind of like that
in seven days kaboom goodbye earth next big
disaster right after avengers end game just
one disaster right after the other tony stark is
rolling in his grave right now what salma hayek's
ajak character is talking about though is the
blip she's talking about the hulk snap bringing
everyone back releasing enough cosmic energy to
accelerate the growth of this celestial inside
earth they give you the flashback powerpoint
presentation this is a celestial being born but
obviously this is all out of sync in the timeline
like the meteorite that seems like it's crashing
to earth sounds like it was the original celestial
egg seeding itself in the planet the people that
would have done that would have been the celestial
host so this giant red celestial that sersi says
is the one that told them not to interfere in the
affairs of man nope don't help out during any of
the wars don't save the earth from thanos that's
arishem the judge he's the leader of the celestial
host the green one later that you see wielding its
cosmic energy seeming like it's creating something
is jemiah the analyzer i talked about this during
my what if video last night the what if episode
2 video a lot of people think that he is actually
nowhere so nowhere is the head of a dead celestial
so we'll see if they pay that easter egg off
during the movie that would be really cool
the way sersi is explaining it to dane whitman's
character kit harington's black knight character
is that they were supposed to come to earth 7,000
years ago to protect the humans from the deviants
that i think is a bit of a lie a lie of omission
because really they're there to guard the growing
celestial egg that's this giant structure
that you see sersitouching as it lights up
with energy connecting this to black panther and
vibranium because they make that vibranium joke at
the end of the trailer in the comics in the past
characters have speculated that the vibranium
mound was actually intended for the creation of
a new celestial body you have to imagine one of
these giant celestials just sort of reaching over
into wakanda saying you know what i'm just going
to take that yo i can just rip it right out of the
ground when they're sitting around in the circle
here all wearing the same clothing i believe
this is them reincarnating this is celestial
energy coming into their bodies the red statue is
meant to be a representation of arishem the judge
eternal's characters can be killed just like
anybody else but they are super strong like
they all have bodies that live for very long
periods of time unless someone kills them
but the reason why they're eternal really is
because they reincarnate into new bodies as
she narrates you see them attacking some of
the deviants this seems like it's when they
first come to planet earth like they're all
standing in formation like the power rangers
we are here amongst you to protect you even though
we have a totally secret mission we're not going
to tell you about the other deviant that you
see later in the trailer talking sounds like
it's going to be Kro who in the comics i believe
has a secret relationship with thena i believe
the idea with the deviants in the movie though
is that the celestials created them to protect
the life that they were seeing around the universe
and then eventually they just went off the rails
and went rogue so then the backup was for the
celestials to create the eternals to take care
of their big mistake with the deviants hopefully
they'll also reference the cosmic hierarchy of the
mcu or the marvel cinematic multiverse because
we have loki the multiverse war he who remains
now but the way it sounds like this plays out in
the timeline of the mcu after avengers end game
it sounds like all this stuff happens this seven
day period before the end of the loki finale even
though when you start talking about time travel
the multiverse it gets a little crazy i think they
just want to keep this movie as simple as possible
because they're introducing so many new characters
so he who remains would know about what's going on
here but for the sake of simplicity i would just
treat the loki finale with the true version of the
multiverse the kang variants sort of manifesting
is happening after the events of the eternals
movie you see all them use their powers just a
little bit they all have slightly different powers
like phastos for instance is the inspiration for
the greek god hephaestus he makes things that's
why richard madden's ikaris character is like
oh this is a perfect shelter you've built here i
bet this is built out of vibranium as he smashes
his table nope that one's ikea all them wield
the same celestial energy that the celestials
themselves wield which is why all their powers
are color coded the same even though they manifest
in slightly different ways like angelina jolie's
character uses celestial energy to fashion weapons
so really the stakes of the movie are that they
have to find a way to either stop this celestial
egg from hatching or to find a way to hatch it
and not destroy the earth in the process and
also stop the celestial host from coming back to
planet earth and wiping it out when the collector
was explaining the history of the universe the
infinity stones and you see issan the searcher
using the power stone to wipe out a planet i'm
also wondering if they're going to connect that
to what's happening in this movie the celestials
are kind of like cosmic gardeners they go around
seeding life on planets and when an experiment
doesn't work out they'll just wipe it out and
start over again but also the way they explain it
in this movie the celestial that's growing inside
earth needs cosmic energy so i'm also wondering if
they'll try to connect it to that guardians of the
galaxy is on the searcher moment with him using
the power stone on that planet seeming like he's
wiping it out but maybe really he was just trying
to unleash cosmic energy to grow another celestial
and hatchet in that planet i did a big video about
kit harington's black knight character and where
he sort of fits into the mcu what his history
is so i'll link that below in the description
but i think the big thing in this movie is that
he's sort of the point of view character learning
about the eternals for the first time and he's
sort of an audience surrogate like who are you
what are you doing here why haven't you helped
us in the past why didn't you stop thanos even
though he's kind of your cousin because this giant
red celestial told us he would squish us like bugs
if we did anything i believe the idea is that
dane whitman's character won't actually become
full-blown black knight till the sequels or other
marvel movies because he is supposed to cross over
into avengers 5 with sersi's character but i think
the idea is that they'll tease his origin towards
the end of this movie like he'll learn about
the ebony blade the curse of his family but i'm
not expecting him to fully wear the armor until
whatever the future sequels wind up being but in
the way they reference the avengers in the last
trailer they're referencing the black panther
characters vibranium in this trailer they're sort
of connecting it to the other marvel movies you
sort of find out where they've been this whole
time and how they were watching all the events
of the mcu movies unfold i know there's going
to be a lot of timeline questions too you also
have to remember that the events of wandavision
take place many weeks after the end of avengers
end game so i'm also assuming that Wandavision
the hex and scarlet witch becoming full-blown
scarlet witch doesn't happen until after the
events of the eternals movie but i think it's
pretty easy to make the assumption that they do
save the planet because none of the other marvel
characters in those projects were addressing a
giant celestial shooting straight up out of the
planet so what'll happen is i'll post my full
breakdown video later today if you have any big
questions about the movie what's going on with the
characters just write them below in the comments
and i'll include it in that full breakdown video
i'll update the link here at the end with the
full breakdown video when i finish posting that
later today and click here for my what if episode
2 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in that next video!